la france à l'unisson depuis le début de
l'après midi déjà les français célèbrent
cette finale de rêve cent mille
personnes sur les 100 et viser le visage
ceint les drapeaux tricolores à la main
et la foule des supporteurs qui
accompagne le départ de l'équipe de
france 2 qu la fontaine vers saint denis
voilà monsieur bonsoir l'événement
promet d'être unique pour cette dernière
coupe du monde du siècle peut être le
rêve à portée de main des tricolores
dans un instant nous retrouverons en
direct au stade de france nos équipes
mais aussi à marseille à lille à
clairefontaine toute la rédaction est
mobilisé on y voit également dans un
instant dans ce journal avec nos
reporter à rio mais d'abord cette fièvre
immense sur la place de l'hôtel de ville
l'équipe de france réclame elle le
soutient les supporteurs elle a été
entendue avant même le début du match
puisque dès cet après midi sur les
champs elysées par milliers ils ont
convergé vers la place de l'étoile
dans une ambiance de fête que les plus
anciens comparé à la liesse de la
libération au point mort les vielles
caroff alice b tulard sur les champs
elysées en réalité une fête énorme
un coup de foudre entre la france et le
brésil
tout l'après midi des dizaines de
milliers de supporters des deux équipes
se sont retrouvées parfois dans la même
voiture
les jaune et vert mélangé au bleu blanc
rouge
difficile de savoir qui soutient la
france et qui souhaitent une nouvelle
victoire brésilienne un grand mélange
des couleurs même si pour les cas de
s'ouvrir c'est clair l'équipe de ronaldo
est absolument imbattable
jouer le temps avait vendu combien des
championnats de l'est
une ferveur qui a de quoi impressionner
les plus blasés des cariocas
j'ai parce que c'est comme moi rio de
janeiro carnaval sous carnaval
auj ocaña vacante totalement cet après
midi peu importe et finalement le
pronostic l'âge ou le mode de locomotion
l'important c'était d'être de la partie
klaxons contre samba match nul devant
les écrans géants installés dans la
capitale
quel que soit le score final dans moins
de trois heures ces supporters langue
déjà guen il était un peu plus de 18h
lorsque le car en menant les tricolores
a quitté clairefontaine vers saint denis
est entouré par une foule compacte
massée devant les grilles du château
l'équipe brésilienne venant 12h
laferrière est arrivée la première au
stade précédent les bleus d'une dizaine
de minutes laurent frédéric bollée il
était 18 heures et il était temps d'y
aller en route pour le grand soir où le
jour le plus long c'est au choix
l'équipe de france quitte clairefontaine
on se croirait sur une étape du tour de
france
le quart a du mal à se faufiler ce sont
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui ont
fait le déplacement pour encourager les
bleus
à l'intérieur il y as aimé jacquet les
22 joueurs et le staff technique
en tout 35 personnes entre
clairefontaine dans les yvelines et
saint denis il est environ 50 kilomètres
ça n'est pas rien il a fallu environ
1h10 pour arriver jusqu'au stade de
france à chaque fois des scènes de
liesse impressionnante
les français qui ont vraiment voulu
accompagner leur équipe et ce départ
depuis la forêt de rambouillet en
restera le symbole est ici que les bleus
ont vécu pendant un mois
c'est d'ici que cette route glorieuse
finalement pas
vers 19h vous donc c'est l'arrivée au
stade de franches
quelques signes de la main peut-être
indicateur d'une ambiance décontractée à
l'intérieur du car en tout cas cette
fois les français sont bien arrivés sur
le lieu où ils sont prêts sans doute à
entrer dans la légende du sport
quant au brésilien ils sont partis de
lésigny en seine-et-marne un trajet
beaucoup moins long que pour les
français
environ une vingtaine de kilomètres
seulement jusqu'à samedi ils sont donc
arrivés une demi heure avant les
français au stade de france
allez savoir si ça ne fait pas déjà 1 0
pour le brésil et tout de suite nous
rejoignons à l'intérieur même du stade
de france à moins d'une heure du coup
d'envoi yens la voix comme de nombreux
français vous n'êtes ni aux couleurs des
tricolores à ce que je vois pas fabien
barthez nous avait dit fini les coster
fini les cravates on veut un vrai public
coloré et de booba on est debout et
colorée et à vrai dire on a le sentiment
ce soir que la coupe du monde démarre
seulement maintenant le public est
fabuleux il ya vraiment une super
ambiance entre les brésiliens et les
français à l'extérieur du stade dans le
stade dans les rues de paris
c'est vraiment une véritable ambiance de
coupe du monde et ça fait très très
plaisir à entendre et à voir surtout le
nom maintenant à la composition de
l'équipe de france aimé jacquet nous
avait promis une surprise aller au
rendez vous la toque ce patrice c'était
de l'intox
ce sera la même équipe que contre la
croatie à une exception près bien sûr
l'entrée en jeu de leboeuf c'était prévu
à la place de laurent blanc puisque
laurent blanc est suspendu vous la
découvrirez en ce moment même vous le
voyez c'est l'équipe bien qu'ils étaient
attendus disons par tout le monde donc
aimé jacquet nous a fait un petit
contre-pied en revanche il ya une énorme
nouvelle qui fait sensation ici
du côté brésilien ronaldo est remplaçant
ronaldo la star mondiale le meilleur
joueur du monde doit apparemment se
ressentir de son genou puisqu'il ne
débutera pas le match
ou du moins il ne débutera mais sur le
banc de touche et ça c'est un point
vraiment capital pour les français qui
vont très certainement jouer ce match
avec coeur ils savent que c'est le
dernier événement sportif mondial du
siècle ils ne veulent pas le manquer et
ne serait ce que pour laurent blanc que
l'on a vu tout à l'heure
juste avant le match des faits
complètement blanc livide
on peut être sûr que les français vont
jouer avec coeur ce soir écouter aimé
jacquet à part ça je pense ça sera le
match du coeur parce que recevoir le
brésil
finale de coupe du monde dans son pays
sur son stade avec toute la france
derrière lui ça peut être que le que le
match du coeur et je dirais de
l'expression place à la fête maintenant
béatrice or on croise les doigts parce
que eh bien on n'a plus grand chose à
attendre trois heures seulement et
peut-être son nouveau champion du monde
merci on vous rejoins tout à l'heure
venons en maintenant aux alentours du
stade les spectateurs ayant la chance de
posséder des billets pour la finale sont
arrivés vers 15 heures saint denis
capitales du monde pour les heures à
venir florent gautreau gmat le match du
siècle a commencé depuis longtemps pour
les supporters mais un match très fair
play ou bleu et jaune n'hésite pas à se
mélanger
dès 15 heures des milliers de brésiliens
s'étaient donné rendez vous au pied du
stade de france saint-denis était jaune
et danser la samba
les brésiliens plus habitué à mettre
l'ambiance occupait alors le devant de
la scène
on a même trouvé des français déguisés
en brésilien s'est pas laissé la légende
vivante
rapidement pourtant le bleu-blanc-rouge
refait surface et la coupe du monde
change de camp
telle est la vraie j'espère que les gens
qui ont mis les cravates ils ont laissé
tomber et qui seront tous haro sur les
costumes les supporters récalcitrants et
est vite repéré voilà son parent pas à
les vieilles pies pour venir des
compacts et à des contacts vous avez mis
la cravate alors que les joueurs
français avaient dit qu'ils voulaient qu
de travail dans les tribunes c'est juste
très juste c'est très juste c'est ma
part avec une cravate et supporters sont
là et même si la samba ne s'arrête pas
on compte sur les français pour stopper
les brésiliens ce soir vers 23h les rois
du monde seront peut-être tout bleu la
fierté l'émotion des habitants du
village natal d'aimé jacquet
sail-sous-couzan près de saint-etienne
était aujourd'hui le rendez-vous des
supporteurs et des touristes
une agitation peu commune sur la place
près de l'église où sera dressé pour la
première fois un écran géant benoît
gadret les forçats de la fête sont déjà
dans la rue azaïs ou poudre ce jour de
finale était aussi un dimanche de fête
patronale
ce serait parce que la saint-jacques est
ce si l'on en croit le match que l'on
rantissi à l'enfant du pays
mémé jacquet projet le connais bien il a
joué en 1958 avec l'huile dans l'équipe
locale niveau de ce qu'il est il était
nettement que de nous il faut
reconnaître non l'été du bourg et
aujourd'hui cette journée pour vous
qu'est ce qu'elle représente
je pourrais ne représente quelque chose
qui me ferait rire et je suis pas je
vous assure que j'ai besoin d'être
rénové on dirait que cheissoux c'est
vrai on dirait que j'ai bu un coup et
puis bon bah non c'est pas vrai du tout
l'émotion on peut la lire dans les yeux
de ceux qui ont connu la famille jacquet
à l'époque où les parents des mais
tenait cette boucherie est ce que les
gens du pays sont fiers jour de mac bien
sûr qu'on est fier mais tous fiers
d'eux-mêmes et parce que c'est un gars
fait droit
12 les plus constants alors rihanna
mancelle à la bouche de son père bah oui
parce que je n'ai b to b b to b
mais non alors maintenant on sait la
gloire de sai la gloire de chaillon la
fêtera au café des sports le café du
village là où ce soir tout peut arriver
pire toutes les chaises ou pascal
plancque quotidienne ah bah je sais pas
j'imagine le pire
seule certitude quel que soit ce soir le
résultat ici ce refrain et en direct de
sail-sous-couzan benoît gadret sur place
en attendant des milliers de supporteurs
qui vont vivre cette finale là où aimé
jacquet a grandi
je n'ai pas entendu votre question je
connais
voir ici
y'a bon copain
ah je comprends et 1000 habitants et on
attend quatre à cinq mille personnes ce
soir les gens sont en train d'arriver
il ya vous
émotion aussi parce que les gens ont été
profondément blessé par les attaques
pour semer jacquet est ce soir au delà
de la victoire
c est en quelque sorte d'une certaine
revanche merci benoît gallerey venons à
marseille maintenant marseille célèbre
zidane l'enfant des quartiers nord
depuis le début du mondial
aujourd'hui c'est toute la ville unie
dans une même ferveur qui s'identifient
à l'équipe de france vincent nguyen
dominique bonnet sur le vieux port il
était rare cet après midi à prédire la
victoire du brésil au bleu et blanc de
son équipe
marseille a rajouté le rouge le drapeau
tricolore flotte dans chaque rue de la
cité phocéenne mercurochrome efforts
marseille la cosmopolite ce soir sera
française avant tout nous étions très
inquiétant
c'est normal non deux à trois
téléviseurs par terrasses les cafés sont
prêts à fêter l'événement les clients
n'ont aucun doute sur l'issue du match
dugarry marc pillu demain
calvin et dîna le brevet qui dort sur la
corniche aussi c'est tout juste si l'on
ne crie pas déjà on a gagné pour les
marseillais la victoire est acquise
grâce à la bonne mère et à l'enfant du
pays bien sûr mais je vous propose de
rejoindre maintenant nos équipes aux
quatre coins de la france à lille mais
aussi à paris sur les champs elysées à
clairefontaine et à marseille marseille
où vous vous trouvez vincent nguyen le
max hoarau transmis dans sur écran géant
sur la plage du prado
oui alors ils étaient 41 milles lors de
la demi finale france croatie
on en attend plus de 50000 ce soir et
l'ambiance comme vous pouvez l'entendre
est plutôt chaude que comme la
température c'est ce qu'il a fait très
beau toute la journée à marseille et les
supporters sont ici en fête sur la plage
depuis le début de l'après midi alors
marseille c'est la vie du football c'est
aussi celle de zinédine zidane et je
peux vous dire qu'ici on attend beaucoup
du joueur on compte beaucoup sur lui
pour offrir la victoire à la france ce
soir
partons maintenant pour lille en direct
mariage masse sur la place charles de
gaulle ici dans cette patrie du football
officiel des enfants des quartiers ont
vécu leur propre au mondial à travers
des compétitions qu'ils ont organisée à
l'image du stade de france
vous voyez donc l'ambiance ce soir
effectivement il ya beaucoup d'ambiance
lille vient de vivre sa finale de la
coupe
elle opposait ça ne s'invente pas les
pays-bas la croatie ce sont les pays bas
qui ont gagné 4 buts à 3 donc mon émoi
les jeunes des quartiers ont vécu leur
mondial le même jour que leurs aînés 64
matches 32 équipes et la france me direz
vous et bien la france elle n'a pas
passé les quarts de finale alors
maintenant retour à la vraie finale
retour à la vraie ambiance
elle a commencé dans les villes
desservies concert de pétards de klaxons
tout ce qui était bleu blanc rouge été
réquisitionnés et à mon avis peu importe
le résultat ce soir il y aura du monde
dans les rues de lille et la peine en
direct de clairefontaine à présent
christelle e bertrand on a vu tout à
l'heure ses images de cette foule
immense qui accompagnait le départ des
tricolores vers saint-denis et je crois
savoir qu'ils seront très nombreux à
attendre leur retour tout à l'heure ah
oui oui moi aussi béatrice je suis
entouré des bleus mais sont des
gendarmes
les forces de l'ordre s'attendent à
recevoir ici plusieurs milliers de
supporters après le match
clairefontaine se prépare on va servir à
dîner aux joueurs à leur retour
on va leur donner aussi un feu
d'artifice donc tout le monde va pouvoir
en profiter et je vous donne rendez vous
pour voir toutes ces images dans
l'édition spéciale de la rédaction
aux alentours de 22h45 merci christelle
les champs elysées rendez-vous symbole
de cette fête du mondial depuis la
victoire en demi-finale des tricolores
cet après midi cent mille personnes
bloqués dans une ambiance bonne enfant
la circulation et on imagine aisément ce
que sera la fête après le match même si
la france ne gagne pas pascal golomer et
bat éjecter la fête elle a déjà commencé
ici bien avant le jeu bien longtemps
pour que depuis ce matin
des centaines de milliers de personnes
défilent le club l'équipe de france dans
un concert de klaxons l'appareil était
une minute
alors évidemment les champs elysées vont
retrouver leur calme sans doute ici
d'ici quelques minutes à ce que le match
va commencer puis toulon va se retrouver
tous retrouvés pour fêter peut-être on
habite en équipe de france
ils étaient 350 milles mercredi soir
après la victoire contre la croatie
on peut imaginer qu'ils battre le record
ce soir ou l'inversé merci pascal
rejoignant maintenant sur le parvis du
stade de france florent gautreau
toujours une ambiance de fête une fête
aux accents français et brésiliens oui
c'est sale ambiance de fête les gens
sont déjà un peu entré dans le stade
mais ceux qui sont derrière moi continue
et bien en fait à festoyer ensemble
c'est une vraie ambiance de fraternité
c'est la finale vous l'entendez derrière
moi c'est la finale de la fraternité
c'est donc une finale de fait à 17h30
les portes se sont ouvertes et les gens
ont commencé à affluer vers le stade de
france ils ont fait la fête ensemble
pendant plus de deux heures
je vais être obligé de vous quitter si
on continue à frapper fort n'y a aucune
tension en fait c'est tranquille et je
peux vous dire qu'ici les gens seront 80
milles on espère que le stade ne sera
pas trop jaune qu'il y aura aussi un peu
de bleu parce que les brésiliens sont
normalement plus habitué à faire la fête
dans les salles mais normalement
l'enfance
à bientôt merci ce matin à la basilique
de saint-denis l'ancien joueur dominique
rocheteau a évoqué cette fraternité que
l'on retrouve dans le sport à cette
prière ci joint la ferveur plus païenne
de quelques vedettes du monde du
spectacle réunit sur les champs elysées
les vedettes s'affiche en bleu blanc
rouge sébastien viverge à gregor c'est
avec une ferveur un peu particulière que
certains fidèles se sont rendus ce matin
à la messe célébrée dans la basilique de
saint-denis situé à quelques centaines
de mètres à peine du stade de france
vermette ingouchie
la zone est une bougie là il faut qu'il
gagne sa gagnoa par par deux buts
d'écart le choeur sud africain de sauver
tôt à chanter la liberté
l'ancien joueur de saint-etienne
dominique rocheteau baptisé jadis l'ange
vert à lui célébré le football qui
rassemble cette année là la fraternité
des hommes qui ne renonce pas à l'enfant
la fête de la tolérance
oui la coupe du monde rassemble des
personnes du toit y allemand pour
imposer leur moyen d'expression
après le bain de spiritualité voici
l'heure des mondanités dans un luxueux
salons parisiens qu'on sait le football
populaire
il fait aussi fureur auprès des stars
fortunés ma grand mère décédée
maintenant maternelle ce après jacques
je l'appelais mais mes kilos mémé
jacquet
c'est ma terre
moi ça me rend assez gai c'est très très
basique avec l'équipe de france ému
je ne serai pas que
je crois qu'on va gagner j'avais un
pronostic
ouais pour moi logique de tout ce beau
monde se retrouvera tout à l'heure aux
places d'honneur du stade de france pour
un match qu'ils espèrent peut aussi
mémorable c'est donc la finale dans tout
le monde rêvait les tricolores face à
l'équipe brésilienne quatre fois
championne du monde le pari d'aimé
jacquet de son équipe
les bleus ont gravi chacun des échelons
de ce mondial pour accomplir leur rêve
d'enfant malgré les esprits chagrins et
les critiques au début ils se sont
imposés voici comment florent gautreau
merci à vous fabien marcel zizou merci à
tous merci d'abord à nicolas anelka
d'avoir laissé sa place à christophe
dugarry dugarry le maudit qui montre la
voie aux français
merci tendrement merci à laurent blanc
pour ce bisou rituel c'est sans doute
pour ça que le chauve souris et qu'il
est capable d'envoyer thierry henry
marquez contre l'arabie merci à lui dit
le frère de thierry qui s'est laissée
dribbler pendant des années sur le
terrain de la cité
pensé à ma famille qu'en fait c'est
quand ça va passer c'est vraiment eux
qui sont l'âme on serait à des amis mais
la famille est toujours là merci à
monsieur brio carter d'avoir expulsé
zinedine zidane zorro coupable de s'être
fait justice lui même
larbitre mexicain a permis au meneur de
jeu français de se reposer pendant dix
jours
un grand merci au ballon fuir 32
panneaux officiels sifa qui a bien voulu
ne pas entrer dans le but de barthez
contre le danemark
merci à ce même ballot qui a eu la
gentillesse de passer dans une forêt de
jambes pour donner à la france la
première place du groupe c
merci bien sûr arrosé luis chilavert
pour sa capacité à faire durer le
suspense merci surtout à lui d'avoir
enfin cédé à la 103e minute du match le
plus crispants du mondial
on sent que il ya une ferveur une
patiente derrière cette équipe et on
fera tout pour que les gens soient fiers
de nous david trezeguet et thierry henry
voudrais remercier spécialement 8 giga
juke pour son tir au but manqué merci
aussi à la barre transversale
cette fois les poteaux n'étaient pas
carré et la france attend le dernier
carré merci à thuram bien sûr qui a
choisi le 8 juillet 98 pour marquer les
deux seuls buts sa carrière chez les
bleus lui qui n'en marquait même pas
avec ses copains de pointe à pitre dans
sa cour d'école
je me disais mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
jeudi route et mais marcel mais marcel
michelin fermaient m viau
qu'est ce qui se passe je dis moi j'en
sais rien ce qui se passe merci davance
à ronaldo pour ce tir sur la barre qui
sauvera les bleus ce soir
merci aux brésiliens de nous en laisser
une merci de nous laisser rêver merci
pour laurent blanc le grand absent
merci pour aimé jacquet pour son
bloc-notes d'écoliers merci pour platini
qui ne l'a jamais gagnée
encore merci et bravo
partons maintenant à rio de janeiro nous
retrouvons en direct de la plage de
copacabana christophe duchiron vous êtes
à l'endroit même où devant des écrans
géants doivent se retrouver la foule
immense des supporteurs brésiliens sous
la pluie eh bien écoutez béatrice la
foule immense aujourd'hui on aura
peut-être du mal à la voir car vous le
voyez je vais pas vous raconter
d'histoires on est en pleine tempête
alors livré qu'à moins d'une heure du
coup d'envoi bien on aurait dû voir les
gens arrivent et on disait de 30 mille
quarante mille cinquante mille personnes
pour venir suivre la rencontre sur
l'écran géant qui se trouve derrière moi
mais évidemment avec le mauvais temps il
y aura sans doute moins de monde
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire eh
bien c'est qu'ici au brésil personnes
imaginent une seule seconde que le
brésil ne remporte pas la coupe du monde
est ce qui nous a frappés ici en
arrivant et bien c'est l'extraordinaire
confiance des gens leur équipe quand on
demande un pronostic c'est pas un zéro
c'est pas victoire aux penalties
ces 3 0 deux buts de ronaldo un but de
veto ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
qu'ici la coupe du monde est un
événement qui dépasse de loin le cadre
du sport et on peut dire que le moral du
pays dans les heures qui viennent et
bien va dépendre du résultat de ce soir
une victoire est bien et c'est la fête
et une défaite
quelqu'un nous disait hier peut-être en
exagérant un petit peu et bien ce seront
ce sera une ambiance de de funérailles
nationales
cela dit un brésilien nous disait aussi
hier soir qu'une défaite finalement ne
fera peut-être pas de mal au brésil tout
ça pour donner un petit peu le sens des
réalités aux gens le pays traverse une
crise économique difficile il y encore
la mise la misère aujourd'hui dans les
favelas mais de tout ça vous en doutez
bien et bien les brésiliens ne penseront
pas une seule seconde pendant la
rencontre de ce soir
merci avec les stocks du chayran est
allé rapidement vous abritez on vous
retrouvera dans l'édition spéciale tout
à l'heure à dublin en irlande le tour de
france après la première étape remportée
par le champion de belgique et homsys le
tour de france se prépare lui aussi
assisté à la finale de ce mondial
depuis ce matin la performance attendue
des tricolores étaient dans tous les
esprits alexandre kara nathalie gallet
sur le tour il ya des jours où l'on ne
changerait pas son maillot bleu pour un
maillot jaune les jours où les champions
se font supporters ou les drapeaux
tricolores illuminé visage allons
enfants du vélo le jour de fou est
arrivée va pas se représenter de les ont
donc
je pense que c'est un homme est un grand
moment et coûte maintenant monsieur
c'est un peu pour l'équipe de france
j'espère déjà que ça n'ira pas jusqu'aux
prolongations voire tirs au but c'est ce
qu'on a envie de dormir ce soir quand
même mais bon
qu'importe la manière pourvu qu'on ait
l'ivresse de la victoire 30-12 attentifs
demain la télé on supporte en a les
français on enfants difficile d'échapper
à la coupe du monde sur le tour ce soit
au royaume du vélo le football sera roi
et il n'y en a pas que les français
devant la télé et je pense qu'elle gagne
la france j'ai presque gagnée par
si des dilemmes italie ces dix concerts
aller à l'essai l'ailier de charbon soit
impliqué dans ce vol avait gagné le bol
certains ici même de faire oublier la
couleur de leurs maillots
on peut regretter que sa branche bien
sûr qu'est ce que j'ai pu dire je suis à
makli français y l'étape terminé la
caravane et les coureurs ont plié bagage
en un temps record ce soir sur le taux
aussi on est en finale
retournant tout de suite au stade de
france avec vous il ya la voix
apparemment vous avez de nouvelles
informations sur la participation ou non
de ronaldo à cette finale c'est quand
même assez incroyable je vais vous
avouer qu'on a des gens de la fifa qui
sont à côté de nous donc lorsqu'on vous
annonçait tout à l'heure que ronaldo ne
jouerait pas ou du moins qu'il serait
remplaçant c'est une information
vraiment confirmé qui nous venaient de
zagallo qui avait annoncé donc
l'entraîneur sur sa feuille de départ
ronaldo remplaçant et à l'instant on
vient de m'annoncer finalement ronaldo
va jouer vous voyez donc que cette coupe
du monde elle a démarré il ya déjà
maintenant une demi heure c'est ça
s'appelle de l'intox ronaldo un coup oui
un coup non c'est pour essayer de
perturber les français en tout cas
ronaldo désormais est couché sur la
feuille de match dès le début et je peux
vous assurer que les brésiliens et jean
va vous montrer un peu le public qui est
derrière moi
les brésiliens vont être ravis de voir
que justement leur ronaldo nationale
sera là pour débuter le match maintenant
dans 40 minutes environ
c'était un peu une rumeur si je vous
comprends bien de manipulation
exactement ça s'appelle de l'intox ça
arrive souvent en foot mais enfin le
jour d'une finale de coupe du monde
c'est vrai qu'on ne s'y attendait pas
merci yann lavoix retour au tour de
france vous le disait il ya un instant
c'est donc tom steels qui a remporté au
sprint cette première étape du tour une
boucle de 180 km le britannique chris
boardman a conservé le maillot jaune de
leader
patrick naf
à quelques kilomètres de l'arrivée à
dublin c'est la chute premier drame de
cette première étape du tour de france
parmi les victimes
mario cipollini l'italien star du sprint
mais aussi ludovic oger le français et
repartiront et termineront très attardé
cette première étape en ligne autour de
dublin une étape de 181 km animé pendant
les deux tiers par une échappée dont les
derniers rescapés
jacky durand et 20 livres seront repris
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
l'arrivée
une arrivée au sprint que les équipiers
de jan ullrich avait préparé pour erik
zabel
mais tom steels en profite pour lui
griller la politesse sur la ligne belle
revanche du champion de belgique
exclu du tour l'an dernier après une
arrivée plus que mouvementée
troisième de l'étape mch event quant à
chris boardman vainqueur du prologue
hier il passe pas une journée
supplémentaire en jaune la sphère de
dopage qui a sombré le départ de ce tour
de france a été évoqué une nouvelle fois
par marie george buffet invités de nos
confrères d'europe 1 le ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports a réaffirmé que
dans ce genre d'affaires il faut aller
jusqu'au bout des coûtants cette enquête
de police que les suites judiciaires qui
sont donnés aille jusqu'au bout il faut
faire il faut aller au bout mais je
crois que beaucoup de médecins du monde
sportif le souhaite parce que ils en ont
notamment les cytises parce qu'ils ont
l'impression d'être toujours marqué je
dirais de ces deux ce soda famille du
dopage et ils ont envie de faire un peu
la transparence la clarté chez ce mois
c'est ce que j'ai senti puisque j'ai
passé deux jours avec tout ce qui en cas
le tour de france et j'ai ressenti cette
volonté majoritaire
alors j'espère qu'il aura pas de blocage
pour moi je ferai en sorte qu'ils aient
pas de blocage fut suffisamment
déterminée malgré parfois les pressions
que je reçois chez chip également
déterminé dans cette lutte pour que l'on
puisse aller au bout et je crois qu'ils
ont pouvait vraiment démantelé une
filière
ça ferait un bon exemple l'un d'eux m
l'actualité à l'étranger en irlande du
nord après la mort de trois enfants
catholiques dans un incendie attribués à
des protestants la tension est montée à
nouveau d'un cran en début d'après-midi
des explosifs abandonné en bord de route
ont été désamorcé par des artificiers
autant de signes tangibles qui inquiète
l'ensemble des dirigeants
éthique la commission des parades a
demandé cet après midi aux orangistes
d'annuler leur marche jérôme ni patrick
desmulie cette nuit apporte donne de
jeunes extrémistes protestants
quant à nouveau après une semaine
d'accrochage de franchir le barrage leur
interdisant l'accès au quartier
catholique
ils sont encouragés par des milliers de
rang gisent près de 100 cocktails
molotov sont envoyés vers les forces de
l'ordre
au même moment à bali monnaies dans le
nord une bombe incendiaire est envoyé
contre cette maison où dormait au
premier étage
richard mart et alyson queen trois
garçons âgés de 7 à 10 ans le quartier
se réveille en état de choc
leur seul tort être les enfants d'un
couple mixte catholiques et protestants
dans un quartier à majorité protestante
c'est certainement lié à ce qui se passe
avec les marches ça augmente la tension
mais je crois que surtout l'oeuvre
d'individus sinistre est malade
cet enfant qui apporte des fleurs est un
cousin des victimes
nous voulions juste déposé des fleurs
c'est tout il n'y a rien à dire
c'est très triste
ce drame a fait fléchir la détermination
d'une partie des orangistes ans 15
minutes de marche dans un quartier
catholique serait une victoire amère à
l'ombre de trois petits chaque oeil les
autorités craignent que ces paroles
d'apaisement ne soient pas entendus les
forces de l'ordre sont plus que jamais
sur le qui vive
on l'aura compris de nombreux
responsables politiques et religieux
demandent aux orangistes de suspendre la
marche prévue aujourd'hui et demain
c'est dire l'inquiétude qui règne en
irlande du nord jérôme boeny
oui béatrice vous voyez derrière moi ce
champ où quand maintenant depuis à peu
près une semaine des orangistes qui
veulent absolument marché dans cette
partie de la ville de porto dans la
partie catholique alors en ce moment
même un dirigeant orangistes du fait de
ce drame dont nous avons parlé dans le
reportage essaie de convaincre la base
de renoncer à cette marche
mais ici du côté catholique on n'y crois
pas trop on est plutôt inquiet
d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre de
familles on a préféré envoyer en irlande
du sud dans la république
les femmes et les enfants c'est un peu
tout le processus de paix qui risque
d'être mise à mal
effectivement tous ceux qui commettent
les violences sont en général des
extrémistes protestants eux sont
persuadés que le processus de paix qui a
été initié il ya trois mois
aboutira au rattachement de l'irlande du
nord à l'irlande du sud
ils font tous donc pour faire capoter ce
processus est aujourd'hui appartenant
comme à belfast comme partout en irlande
du nord les forces de sécurité sont sur
le qui vive les les villes sans
véritable état de siège car demain comme
vous le savez c'est le point d'orgue de
toutes les marches et les risques
d'incidents sont particulièrement
importants merci jérôme ni au japon les
résultats des élections sénatoriales met
en difficulté le premier ministre hashim
auto qui devrait rapidement démissionné
on attend l'annoncé de cette démission
dans les heures qui viennent
le premier ministre victimes du séisme
économique qui touche le japon et qu'il
n'aurait pas pu maîtriser jean-paul
chapelle à la tête du gouvernement
japonais ces heures sont comptées
ryutaro hashimoto le sait mais il
attendra les résultats complets pour
démissionner
tout est entièrement de ma faute le
parti libéral qu'il préside vient de
subir un sérieux revers
on profite du parti démocratique et du
parti communiste
l'enjeu du scrutin dépasse largement le
strict renouvellement du sénat
le pays traverse sa plus grande
récession jamais connue depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale
du coup la participation atteint 60%
historique le vote prend des allures de
référendum
je veux voir le changement tout de suite
pas demain mais aujourd'hui le parti au
pouvoir garde la majorité dans l'autre
assemblée la chambre basse la seule
faisant vraiment autorité
il devrait donc conserver la direction
du gouvernement mais l'incertitude
politique à tokyo risque d'agiter les
marchés financiers la crise de confiance
que connaît la deuxième puissance
économique du monde aggrave chaque jour
l'instabilité financière en asie à
madrid un an après la mort de miguel
angel blanco ce jeune élu municipal
exécuté par le thé à manifestation
silencieuse rassemblant plusieurs
milliers de personnes pour réclamer la
paix les chaînes de télévision
consacrées de nombreuses émissions
spéciales à cet événement et des
cérémonies ont eu lieu à travers le pays
rassemblant des responsables politiques
de toutes tendances au nigeria le
principal opposant au régime
abiola qui a été enterré hier serait
bien d'essayer bus rouge naturel
ce qu'a déclaré son fils après les
résultats de l'autopsié pratiquée par
une équipe internationale de
spécialistes
la mort serait due à une crise cardiaque
retour au sport le grand prix de formule
1 l'écurie mclaren mercedes a déposé une
réclamation après la victoire de michael
schumacher
les résultats sont donc officieux pour
l'instant laurent frédéric bollée
michael schumacher vient de gagner et il
ne le sait pas encore c'est moi vraiment
de vente il et oui c'est lui y est pas
mika hakkinen qui termine seulement 2e
schmacher qui triomphent dans un grand
prix rocambolesque du 43e au 49e tour la
course est en effet neutralisés la pluie
est trop forte sur silverstone un grand
prix d'angleterre dantesques et fatale
pour david coulthard tu l'écossais sur
la deuxième mclaren ne résiste pas aux
conditions extrêmes de piste ou plutôt
une glisse même mika hakkinen seul
leader n'échappe à une impressionnante
figure l'a même vu sous un autre angle
on est alors au 42e tour et là
franchement ça devient quasiment
impossible de courir dans ces conditions
après une neutralisation d'un quart
d'heure voici donc venu le temps d'un
nouveau départ lancé à kinnen prend le
meilleur envol schumacher est prêt au
rush final et de boucles plus tard coup
de théâtre à keenan tire tout droit
schumacher qu'elle la première place à
neuf tours de l'arrivée madame aquitaine
peut être déçu son mari a cédé mais ça
n'est pas tout il reste 500 mètres à
parcourir à schumacher avant de gagner
et surprise il s'arrête à son stand
suite à une pénalité incroyable c'est à
qui n'aiment qui passe le premier sous
le drapeau à damier mais ça ne marche
pas même dans les stands c'est comme si
je suis majeur avait aussi passé la
ligne avant le finlandais schumacher qui
empoche donc sa 31e victoire au
championnat il grignote de plus en plus
son retard
deux petits points le séparent désormais
de mika hakkinen
et puis on apprend mais tout juste à
l'instant que la réclamation de mclaren
a été rejetée c'est donc michael
schumacher qui remporte bien ce grand
prix de grande bretagne en france l'été
des festivals avec ce festival itinérant
à bord d'une péniche sur le canal du
midi une manifestation qui se déplace et
qui amène la fête sur le canal des deux
mers
christophe la rocca gilbert rozon chaque
jour la péniche musarde sur le canal des
deux mers entre narbonne et bordeaux
elle va son train de sénateur
aujourd'hui c'est andré un ancien du
transport de marchandises qui l'amène à
bon port
le temps d'une escale le sommeil
c'est l'une des plus belles étapes sur
le canal 18 la péniche d'andré s'est
transformé en scènes de spectacles
douchement le festival s'installe dans
la torpeur d'un après-midi langue le
dossier concret de la vie comme ça doit
être partout la concurrence y est ça
veut dire vivre ensemble vivre ensemble
au lieu de vivre à côté donc nous avec
avec notre outil avec ce que l'on sait
faire avec nos bateaux on propose ça sur
l'endroit où on est
car c'est vrai qu'il commençait à
ressembler à un musée ce canal du midi
si beau qu'il est aujourd'hui classé
patrimoine de l'unesco
ce festival gratuit ramin admis le
public populaire des environs qui ne
goûte pas une programmation de qualité
il n'y a pas de concession de fait et je
crois que ça aussi c'est bien c'est bien
on joue ce compte qu'on joue d'habitude
le public ne reçoit comme ça m'a froissé
phase assez bien le temps d'une soirée
grâce à ce festival itinérant le canal
retrouve la vie festive de sa grande
époque celle des marines avec un bal
concertant menée par michel macias face
à un quai qui a dû jadis voir tant de
têtes tournées le canal du midi a brisé
son écrin et redevient pour un soir une
bien belle en diable il faudrait que ça
soit mais bob dylan est comme ça le
lendemain
andré reprendra sa route lui qui a connu
la fin du fret qui à transporter des
passagers
le voilà sans regret dans le spectacle
je pense qu'on renoue avec la tradition
du colportage même s'il s'agit de traces
porter un podium pour le festival
c'est passé le village en village s'est
créé une animation et après tout
pourquoi pas s'il peut ainsi lui andré
continuer à vivre sur son canal devant
le mur légendaire du théâtre antique le
festival d'orange propose carmen l'opéra
le plus joué au monde depuis plus d'un
siècle la qualité de la mise en scène et
la chaleur des voix pour un spectacle
réussi georges bigot michel levasseur
carmen c'est une histoire de coeur une
sorte de choeur antique qu'ils suivent
comme ample action c'est aussi un
fabuleux pretec sa chanson chanson qui
appartiennent à notre mémoire collective
et
a sévi comme partout les enfants aiment
jouer au soldat a fusillé pour de rire
leurs camarades mais ce qui leur échappe
c'est le sens profond de septembre une
autre histoire de coeur celui de
permettre la femme libre par qui le
scandale arrive
ça
ouais
carmen propose toutes les facettes d'un
personnage d'une et notamment d'une
femme blonde en dans l'humour dans la
tendresse dans la violence dans la dans
la souffrance dans la passion et c'est
pour ça que j'adore ses personnages
photo
et
qui saurait être de pierre sinon on peu
robuste devant l'ardeur de béatrice uria
monzon qui donne un carmen toute la
flamboyance du rôle
en
retour au mondial avec tout à l'heure au
stade de france le défilé de 300
mannequin célébrant les 40 ans de mode
d'yves saint laurent une mer bleue sur
la pelouse verte du stade et des top
models qui est des ambühl au rythme des
tambours se fumer elle sans percussion
nist battant à tout rompre leurs bidons
de métal les metalovoice rythme ce soir
un défilé exceptionnel 300 modèles
retraçant 40 ans de création du saint
laurent
le couturier le plus respecté le plus
adulé celui qui a le plus inspiré la
jeune génération
des mannequins qui flottent par vagues
successives sur un ciel suspendu
l'ensemble a été orchestré en 22
tableaux et six grands thèmes dont l'art
qui a toujours aspiré le couturier
depuis ses débuts ici carla bruni et ses
colombes de la paix dans l'oubli qui
sans laurent longtemps considéré comme
un grand classique a été le premier à
choquer en déshabillant les femmes mais
à oran sous le soleil exactement
le couturier a toujours eu un faible
pour la couleur pour les orientales
la slovaque adriana fiancée du joueur 40
bleus portent ici une robe shéhérazade
je vais
quarante ans de création de douceur de
beauté 40 ans de joie yves saint laurent
à vous ne regrettez qu'une seule chose
aujourd'hui ne pas avoir inventé le
vêtement universel ainsi se termine
cette édition nous refermons ce journal
sur ces images en direct de l'hôtel de
ville la fête du football à quelques
minutes maintenant du coup d'envoi une
fête joyeuse inouïe qui devrait se
poursuivre toute la nuit
la rédaction est mobilisée puisque une
édition spéciale ce soir dès 23h45 et
pour toute la nuit tu rendras compte de
cet événement historique
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
c'est fait